au cœur de l'inspection du travail alors
je le disais en présentant l'émission
tout à l'heure il y a ceux qui disent
que à force de protéger les salariés et
bien on finit par décourager l'emploi
autrement dit notre réglementation du
travail notre code du travail serait
tellement contraignant touffu obsolète
qu'il finirait par décourager les
investisseurs et l'emploi et puis il y a
ceux qui disent qu'au contraire partant
de crise il est jamais aussi important
que de protéger le salariés que
aujourd'hui alors on va parler de tout
ça avec nos invités on va parler de ça
des conditions de travail de leur
évolution et notamment de la montée des
risques psychosociaux on nous expliquera
ce que ça veut dire et autour de la
table pour parler de tout ça et bien
Florence baral bouté vous vous êtes
directrice adjointe du travail dans
l'iser vous êtes aussi secrétaire
général de Force Ouvrière pour les
questions de d'inspection du travail et
droit du travail tout à fait en face de
vous Guillaume kerou vous êtes président
du club des entrepreneurs et PDG de
didxis alors j'essaie de vous faire n
expliquer ce que c'est que didaxisme
alors c'est une espèce de conglomérat de
nébuleuse dans laquelle vous vous
apporte
entreprise c'est une entreprise de
taille intermédiaire qui travaille dans
les services des services à forte valeur
ajoutée dans l'ingénierie jusqu'au
service à la personne donc une très
large palette de métiers
aujourd'hui qui représente aujourd'hui
5000 emplois en France et qui a été créé
il y a 10 ans par mois lorsque je me
recherchais mon propre emploi d'accord
vous avez créé un emploi puis une F en
éiguille vous fait 5000 Étienne CIN vous
êtes avocat spécialisté sur les
questions de droit du travail et puis
Daniel linart nous rejoindra elle est
sociologue elle est directrice de
recherche au CNRS mais on va commencer
bien sûr tradition oblige par vous
jean-ve Cochard vous êtes le réalisateur
de ce film un mot sur le le titre
puisque on l'a pas dit mais l 6111 c'est
quoi c'est l'article de loi qui donne le
pouvoir aux inspecteurs du travail de
dresser procès-verbal et de constater
les infractions c'est la base la be
juridique de leur action voilà c'est un
corps de fonctionnaires qui a été créé
en
1892 et avec la mission de garantir le
les droits des salariés et de prévenir
les accidents du travail alors pourquoi
ce choix de sujet qui est pas très
courant quand même il y avait un
contexte à l'époque quand on a réalisé
le film 2004 deux inspecteurs de
contrôleurs du travail sont tués lors
d'un contrôle par un agriculteur en
Dordogne il y a un émoi il y a un gros
malaise au sein de la la des
fonctionnaires c'est un corps qui parle
pas beaucoup qui c'était difficile de
mettre une caméra mais là en en fait il
y avait un tel malaise que ils ont eu
envie il y avait un troplein
quoi je crois que le double meurtre de
de 2004 révélit également au grand
jour un peu l'ingratitude de leur
tâchees et tout un climat un peu haineux
qu'il avait autour de l'inspection du
travail parce que c'est vrai que c'est
une administration qui est pas facile à
pénétrer comme on dit enfin sont est
ferm les gens font leur boulot ils sont
tenus d'ailleurs vous me disiez à une
sorte de secret hein professionnel vous
pouvez pas dire ce que vous faites dans
entreprise ni quel rapport vous avez
avec les salariés ou avec les employeurs
on a on peut quand même si on a on peut
on a des secrets à respecter notamment
les secrets de fabrication bon et donc
faire venir la presse c'est jamais une
pas une coutume chez vous et vous TZ
bien accueilli on vous a admis sur tous
les terrains vous avez pu travailler
exactement comme vous le vouliez
principalement oui mais la difficulté
moi je voulais filmer principalement
pourquoi il y a eu des c'est interdit il
y a des choses des employeurs qui
voulaient pas qu'on filme par exemple
lors d'un contrôle c'est arrivé euh et
comme moi je voulais privilégier la vie
et pouvoir vraiment utiliser une mettre
une caméra au sein d'une section de de
l'inspection du travail c'était pour moi
pénétrer au cœur du monde du travail et
essayer de regarder ce monde du travail
en mutation en évolution voir
l'évolution des rapports sociaux donc
euh
euh c'était pas toujours facile parce
que il y a des chos qui était euh
je dans le film on voit à un moment
donné il rentre dans un restaurant
chinois où en fait le type ça'avère être
un véritable marchand de sommeil bon euh
j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir tourner
cette séquence il y avait d'autres
choses où j'ai pas malheureusement pu
tourner voilà on vous a dit non donc là
l'accueil est pas toujours très bon et
et et ce mal des patron souvent des fois
qui sont toujours un peu méfiants quand
on parle d'inspection du travail ou de
voit pas AR je sais pas quand vouspend
enfin moif grosso modo aujourd'hui c'est
vrai qu'on a on a dans dans dans mon
entreprise on a une dizaine de contrôles
en cours ça se passe très très bien
c'est vrai en cours en simultané c'està
dire que aujourd'hui quand vous avez une
entreprise qui a une très forte
croissance c'est vrai que pour certaines
administrations c'est suspicieux et
c'est vrai que c'est un peu l'attitude
en tout cas des contrôleurs et qu'on va
essayer de de de remettre dans la
réalité de de notre quotidien on est là
pour créer des emplois on n'est pas là
pour s'opposer aux administrations sur
le malaise don vous parliz au début on
en parlera avec vous tout à l'heure bien
sûr mais sur ce des inspecteurs de
travail en quoi ils se sentent mal en
quoi ça va pas bien en quoi sent mal
aimés oui ils sonts sont mal aimés en
fait ce sont des gens qui quand ils
arrivent sur le terrain pour un contrôle
se font pour la plupart du temps soit
insulté soit maltraité physiquement ou
agressé c'est arrivé dans le
documentaire que j'ai tourné il y avait
quelqu'un qui avait bousculé et agressé
physiquement un contrôleur donc c'est un
peu comme les flics les flics sont les
les les les malaimés de euh de la voie
publque pour des serviteurs je dirais de
la République ouais et àé il y a un
tropelin quoi et ce sont les patrons
évidemment qui sont assez remonter
contre eux quand il dév arriver parce
que ce sont des empêcheurs de travailler
tranquillement j'imagine et les
salariésx même est-ce qu'ils vont
naturellement se tourner vers les
inspecteurs est-ce que ils leur écrivent
beaucoup est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup de
délations est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup de
d'alertes sur des situations
condamnablesoui en fait ils ont une base
de de de de de de collecte
d'informations sur sur des courriers sur
beaucoup de mais aussi j'étais très
surpris quand j'ai réalisé le film tous
les appels qui tombent chaque jour sur
les lignes téléphoniques pour des
salariés qui se plaignent de harcèlement
de souffrance au travail ah et vous
faites quoi avec ces appels
vous déjà on donne on donne les
renseignements sur les le code du
travail hein puisque souvent les
personnes nous demandent est-ce que mon
patron a le droit de faire ça est-ce que
c'est c'est souvent ça au début hein le
renseignement jque c'est du conseil
juridique c'està-dire effectivement
est-ce que il me paye bien mes heures
supplémentaires comme il le devrait
est-ce que qu'est-ce que prévoit la
convention collective pour le paiement
des heures supplémentaires donc c'est du
renseignement au départ c'est on donne 6
millions de renseignements par an euh
donc à la fois par téléphone par mail
maintenant on reçoit par mail on reçoit
auss c'està du renseignement etvec ça dé
ça dénonce une situation qui est après
il alors il y a un service renseignement
hein donc dans les les unités
territoriales spécifiques he donc on
reçoit à la fois physiquement les
salariés et aussi par on reçoit les
appels téléphoniques donc il y a un
double accueil et quand il y a des
situations qui relèvent plus d'un
contrôle c'est-à-dire d'une intervention
des agents de contrôle à ce moment-là on
dirige la personne vers les sections
d'in ça peut déclencher du contrôle
voilà le renseignement peut déclencher
un contrôle bien sûr même si c'est
anonyme il faut toujours s'assoir alors
là il y a un compte de déontologie qui
est très clair pour l'inspection du
travail he c'est que nous avons une
obligation de ne J révélé une plainte
hein donc c'està-dire que donc les gens
peuvent s'adresser à vous en toute
confiance ils seront pas dénoncés ils
n'apparîont pas dans une procédure on
saura pas que ce sont eux qui ont mis
qui ont alerté votre votre vigilance on
est on est très clair là-dessus
c'est-à-dire quand il nous demande une
intervention on leur dit toujours que ça
sera anonyme c'est-à-dire que quand on
va dans une entreprise on ne dit jamais
pourquoi on est
là si c'est sur plainte ou pas sur
plainte parce qu'on fait des contrôles
qui sont pas forcément sur plainte il y
a des contrôles classiques donc le
patron c'est pas effectivement ce qui
vous avvez amené à voilà absolument et
donc c'est et ça c'est une
obligation morale et juridique très
importante c'est-à-dire qu'on doit
jamais dévoiler l'origine de la plainte
puisque évidemment le salarié peut
craindre pour son emploi donc ça c'est
vraiment très fort dans nos très
prignant dans nos services le film il
vous a plu ou pas le film globalement
c'est vrai qu'il est il est très bien
très bien structuré très bien très bien
mis en scinene on va dire maintenant
c'est vrai que moi en tant
qu'entrepreneur je trouve que que
s'adresse un portrait bien noir de
l'entreprise je pense que l'entreprise
en tout cas l'entreprise en tout cas que
moi je dirige les entreprises que je
vois au quotidien sont assez assez
éloignés de de de la réalité qui est
filmée ici même si je ne ni pas que ça
existe c'est vrai qu'il y a des
situations qui sont inadmissibles
notamment lorsque ça met en danger la
vie d'un certain nombre de salariés je
pense notamment au chantiers de travaux
publics à des conditions de travail dans
des restaurants des fois plutôt ancest
donc ces situations là effectivement
doivent être dénoncé ça donne une vision
un peu trop clivante de
l'opposition salarié employeur parce que
effectivement la réalité de de de des
employeurs en tout cas et des
entrepreneurs que je côtoie au quotidien
ne sont pas dans cette dynamique là on a
beaucoup de petits de petites structures
peut-être de petits commerces là il y a
un restaurant effectivement restaurant
chinois mais au-delà de ça je crois que
les les entrepreneurs il faut faire un
constat ils sont face à un du travail
aujourd'hui qui va bientôt faire 3400
pages il y a une page de créer tous les
3 jours vous savez pour un entrepreneur
qui qui qui essaie de développer de
créer des emplois au quotidien c'est pas
simple nul n sensé ignorer la loi ce que
fait effectivement ce que nous rappell
les administration là c'est pas possible
le problème c'est ça le vrai problème il
est là par on va faire venir juste un
mot par j'embr directement parce que je
suis en train de préparer un
documentaire sur la souffrance patronale
mais existe et ça par que c'est quelque
chose de céit vraiment un tabou en
France mais il semblerait d'après des
études et des statistiques que deux deux
patrons deux patrons de PME qui se
suicident chaque jour en France puis
au-delà des relations aussi conjugales
et cetera enfin moi aujourd'hui on
traverse une crive qui est très très
grave aussi bien au niveau des des des
des des des salariés qui rechercheent un
emploi mais aussi des entreprises qui
aujourd'hui n'en peuvent plus c'est
qu'il y a beaucoup d'entrepreneurs
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'entrepr ur au
niveau du CL envie de jeter l'éponge et
là alors il y a ce pack de
responsabilité qui arrive peut-être une
bouffée d'oxygène pour nos entreprise
mais il y a un signal d'alarme il y a il
y a des des risques psychosociaux pas
que vers les salariés mais également
vers ses employurs alors on va faire
venir daniel Merci beaucoup de d'être
venu et on va voir un extrait de votre
documentaire et c'est un échange je
crois ù une de votre personnage
principal qui nous raconte un petit peu
bah ce que c'est que l'inspection du
travail on a un code du travail et des
outils qui permettent quand même à mon
avis de bien travailler
aujourd'hui mais on est trois agents de
contrôle par section dans une section on
compte à peu près 3700 entreprises sans
parler des
chantiers
euh voilà
voilà donc on se débrouille comme on
peut et c'est assez miraculeux que les
gens connaissent quand même vaguement ce
que c'est que l'inpect du travail parce
qu'avec ces chiffres là il a des
entreprises qui voient pas l'ombre d'un
agent de contrôle même une fois tous les
10 ans il fait croire que pour l'État
ben ce chiffre là convient mais on fait
avec hein et les entreprises font avec
et les salariés font avec voilà ce que
dit cette inspectrice du travail merci d
Linard de nous avoir rejoint je le
disais vous êtes sociologue directrice
de recherche au CNS un mot sur le film
que vous avez vu aussi il vous a plu sur
ce que ça révèle de ce monde de l'inpect
du travail oui j'ai trouvé très
intéressant parce que précisément on
voit à quel point il y a un malaise qui
se profile lorsquapparaissent les
inspecteurs du travail il y a cette idée
souvent que c'est pas très légitime
qu'est-ce qu'ils font là ils viennent
déranger des gens qui travaillent et ça
je trouve ça très intéressant parce que
ça reflète bien l'opinion publique qui a
tendance à dire que en France le code du
travail est surprotecteur et que ça
c'est vraiment un handicap pour des
employeurs et il y a quelque chose on
qui reflète bien l'opinion publique qui
a tendance à dire en France on n pas
intérêt à se plaindre euh tout se passe
bien comparativement à d'autres pays
d'ailleurs on a entendu on on parle de
la Chine de l'Inde et effectivement
c'est très révélateur cette cette façon
dont les inspecteurs du travail sont
perçus oui vous interrogiez tout à
l'heure sur les raisons pour lesquelles
les inspecteurs du travail étaient pas
toujours bien accueillis dans les
entreprises il y a aussi le fait que il
y a un fond euh de sauce dans le débat
aujourd'hui public qui est que le droit
du travail serait la cause de beaucoup
des déboirs de cette société de la
situation du chômage des difficultés
rencontrées par les entreprises donc
faut pas s'étonner qu'il y
aitemp à force si on présente tout le
temps le droit du travail et la
protection des salariés comme un frein à
l'emploi faut pas s'étonner qu'en retour
il soit parfois un petit peu difficile
pour les inspecteur du travail d'être
correctement accueilli dans les
entreprises l'inspecteur du travail il
faut le dire c'est le relais de
proximité pour tous les salariés de ce
pays sans distinction c'est-à-dire que
c'est le seul outil dont il dispose pour
faire valoir le droit le reportage
leande très bien et pour solliciter un
recours dans les difficultés qu'il
rencontent c'est pas les avocats qui
peuvent le faire nous on est sollicité
uniquement dès lors que les salariés ont
la culture pour le faire les moyens pour
le faire et qu'ils sont déjà dans une
logique Judici intervenir dans
l're intervenir dans l'entreprise on a
évidemment pas les on évidemment pas les
prérogatives de pouvoir public et puis
toute façon on ne fait que ce qu'on nous
demande de faire et et on ne choisit pas
là où on intervient donc c'est c'est
c'est une différence majeure on n pas du
tout sur unot làdessus ou c'est que le
contrat de travail c'est un contrat de
subordination juridique c'est-à-dire que
l'employé dépend de son patron et ça
c'est le seul tiers extérieur qui vient
et qui peut un peu rééquilibrer le le
rapport de force qui est inscrit dans le
cadre du du contrat de travail vous êtes
d'accord avec ça Florence bar parce
qu'il il y a quand même les syndicats
vous êtes à la fois inspectrice et
syndicalistes les syndicats il sont
aussi dans l'entreprise c'est bien bah
oui l'inspection du travail mène au
syndicalisme c'est quelquefois
effectivement bah oui ça va souvent
enensble puisque un inspecteur du
travail travaille avec les syndicalistes
du secteur privé donc on sait à quel
point les syndicalistes sont des des
forces très importantes dans
l'entreprise he pour Ben pour qu'il y
ait un dialogue social qui se fasse
entre les employeurs et les salariés et
que ce sont aussi des personnes très
exposés vous vous ressentez comme quoi
vous sentez comme proche plutôt des
salariés proche des syndicats ou proch
de tout le monde justement notre métier
c'est d'être proche de tout le monde
parce que Mo viment ou quand même vous
arrivez dans la boîte en vous disant je
suis un peu Zoro jeis un peu défendre
non non on ça dépend dans quel cadre non
non on n'est pas zo parce que je
voudrais là j'ai pas eu l'occasion de
m'exprimer sur le film mais je voudrais
dire que le film reflète réellement la
réalité du métier l'inspecteur et le
contrôleur du travail par sa richesse et
et sa diversité euh la diversité on voit
bien les interlocuteurs des contrôleurs
inspecteurs du travail au début ils ont
deux salariés qui parlent pas français
hein ensuite ils ont un un un
établissement où les les salariés
parlent toujours pas français il parlent
une autre langue après vous êtes dans la
métallurgie avec un chef d'entreprise de
PME où il y a des machines qui sont pas
conformes et et donc là on voit la
richesse du métier parce que la machine
n'est pas conforme on voit bien que
l'employeur il dit oui mais bon je fais
ce que je peux avec les moyens que j'ai
et donc toute la la la richesse du
métier d'inspecteur du travail ça va
être d'évaluer qu'est-ce qui va comment
il va conduire l'entreprise à appliquer
la réglementation et dans cet exemple
c'est très fr sans menacer pour autant
l'entreprise sans la faire couler B sans
la menacer en appliquant en appliquant
les moyens juridiques que nous donne le
code du travail donc il y a toute
l'appréciation la machine est non
conforme qu'est-ce qu'on fait on va
faire une mise en demeure de conformité
de la machine qui qui va coûter cher à
l'entreprise est-ce que on lui dit bah
vous allez commencer par mettre les
arrêts d'urgence que je vous demande là
c'est ça coûte un peu moins cher et
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de l'apprenti sur
lequel l'employeur par exemple fait du
chantage renir mais votre souci c'est ça
le métier d'inspect votre souci c'est de
faire en sorte que l'entreprise
fonctionne quand même bien ou est-ce que
vous êtes surtout attentif à débusquer
ce qui ne va pas pour pénaliser si je
puis dire non non le patron non notre
but le but de l'inspection du travail
c'est que la réglementation du travail
soit appliquée dans les entreprises elle
est pas là pour taper sur les
entreprises c'est appliquer la
réglementation et notre travail c'est de
dire aux
entreprises ce vers quoi elles doivent
tendre ce qu'elles doivent faire pour
arriver à appliquer cette réglementation
pour la protection des salariés qui
travaillent parce que bon une machine
non avec uneillante pour les impératifs
économiques du patron vous dites ben
c'est alors c'est pas bienveillant c'est
ça fait partie je dirais pas qu'on est
bienveillant vis-à-vis des employeurs
mais je dirais que c'est c'est une ça
rentre dans le jugement et dans les
suites qu'on va donner au contrôle
effectivement ça va rentrer dans les
paramètres tout ça rentre et ben oui
c'est un tout
c'estance oui il y a toute une dimension
de l'activité des inspecteurs du travail
qui n'est pas montrée dans le reportage
sans doute parce qu'elle est un peu
moins tégénique mais qui est essentiel
et qui est moins conflictuel c'est le
rôle joué par l'inspection du travail
par exemple pour tout ce qui est
l'animation du processus électoral les
élections professionnelles dans les
entreprises l'administration du travail
et compét chaque fois qu'il y a pas
d'accord pour trancher les questions lié
à l'organisation du processus électoral
en l'absence d'accord et donc on voit
bien le rôle de l'administration qui est
de rechercher et d'être un petit peu le
garant du bon dialogue social et de la
recherche du dialogue social dans
l'entreprise avec toujours la menace de
l'application de la loi c'est le
dialogue abouti pas il y a toujours
c'est un arbitre et c'est un magistrat
social parce que c'est y a un côté
magistrature dans le rôle de
l'inspection du travail c'est-à-dire que
on est toujours un peu en recherche de
la vérité aussi parce que quand on
accueille un salarié dans nos
permanences et quand on va faire le
contrôle d'entreprise et qu'on entend la
version de l'employeur on se dit mais
est-ce qu'on me raconte la même histoire
parce qu'il y a deux versions totalement
opposées de la même analyse de la même
situation donc notre rôle ça va être de
dire d'aller chercher des éléments
factuels pour
porter une analyse et donner les suites
qui nous semblent être devoir être donné
en terme d'effectif he parce que j'ai
cité ces chiffres là il y en aura
peut-être d'autres à citer mais ceux
sont quand même assez parlants 2300
inspecteurs et contrôleurs si j'ai bien
compris
1800000 entreprises 18 millions de
salariés 265000 contrôles grosso modo
100000 entreprises de de quel type
d'entreprise on parle toute entreprise
confond d'accord parce que c'est vrai
qu' avec si on intègre les les les les
indépendants on a 3400000 entreprises ah
non pas les profession libérale hein là
c'est les entreprises entreprises avec
des salariés et et 265000 interventions
en 2012 si je m'abuse euh vous êtes
assez vous êtes pas assez euh il y a
cont quelqu'un qui dit la dame nous dit
bah il y a des entreprises qu' voit pas
uninspecteur avant 10 ans bon V c'est
vrai c'est vrai mais elle a raison mais
j'aime bien quand elle dit on fait ce
qu'on peut avec les moyens qu'on a ben
oui c'est un peu ça parce que bah le le
le les chantiers sont immenses hein pour
l'inspection du travail les demandes
sont innombrables donc après on priorise
nos interventions par rapport au nombre
d'agent de contrôle que nous
sommes on parlait du rapport que le chef
d'entreprise peut avoir avec
l'inspecteur ou trcee du travail la
façon tu la vois arriver vous-même vous
dites que j'ai j'ai quatre contrôles en
cours en ce moment oui non mais en 10 an
en 10 an moi j'ai j'ai j'ai eu
l'occasion de de d'être contrôlé suite à
des dénonciations de salariés avec qui
j'avais j'avais un une salarié avec qui
j'avais un contentieux et c'est vrai que
j'ai eu j'ai eu j'ai eu j'ai eu la la
surprise
d'être d'être considéré comme comme un
comme un malfrain c'est qu'il y a eu une
une brigade qui est descendue dans
l'entreprise limite perquisition alors
ça c'était c'était au départ bon après
j'essaie de dédramatiser aussi la
situation parce que je moi j'ai rien à
me reprocher on est on est à jour de de
de de toute la réglementation sociale
euh et puis au fil au
du non parce que au fil du temps c'est
lié justement avec cette cette brigade
de de de de inspection du travail une
relation de proximité elle a bien
compris qu'elle avait en face un
entrepreneur qui faisait les choses du
mieux qu'il pouvait et effectivement
quand on recrute 9000 salariés en
l'espace de 10 ans bien évidemment qu'il
y a certains salariés qui peuvent se
sentir laés appr à vous connaître ça VO
voilà et c'est intéressant quand même de
de cette cet échange aujourd'hui c'est
vrai qu'on est entouré même je moi je
suis je suis un un soutien de de d'une
de notre future mère de probablement de
Paris qui est une ancienne inspectrice
du travail qui aujourd'hui fait un un
grand travail aussi sur sur
l'entrepreneuriat parce que c'est c'est
là le le le vrai problème c'est qu'on n
pas suffisamment aussi aujourd'hui dans
la dans le contexte de chômage qu'on
connaît d'employeurs et que les les
créations d'entreprises aujourd'hui qui
se font se font sans emploi à la clé et
donc ça c'est c'est le vrai problème ça
al l'administration et l'administration
a un rôle l'administration justement je
pense en amont on a une mutation du du
marché du travail moi je pense que
l'administration soit fiscale travail et
cetera pourrait en amont avoir un rôle
d'accompagnement de ces entreprises qui
ont potentiellement la possibilité de
créer des emplois et effectivement dans
des métiers des FO un peu complienir sur
ce rapport qui est pas toujours aussi
facile entre inspection du travail
entrepreneur et mais revenons au
documentaire avec ce petit extrait on
voit justement comment Nathalie Meyer
bah se retrouve confronté à un patron
qui lu dit bah c'est comme ça votre
stagiaire hier il va rentrer chez
lui vous avez un apprenti qui a moins de
18 ans ici vous auriez dû demander une
dérogation et là vous l'avez pas
aujourd'hui puisqueelle est pas arrivée
jusqu'à nous la demande et ben
l'apprenti va retourner chez lui puis
c'est tout que je vous dis si on peut
pas apprendre le métier au jeunes et ben
il va retourner chez lui puis c'est tout
ça se règle comme ça plus d'apprenti
vous rendez pas compte de la charge de
travail qu'on a je crois que vous rendez
pas bien
compte faut pas me demander non plus
vous reconnaissez problème le problème
c'est qu'on ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il y
a un entrepreneur qui qui qui qui n'a
pas les moyens administratif et
probablement pas les ressources parce
que c'est quoi l'autre problème c'est la
taille de entreprises françaises quand
vous avez euh 80 quasiment 90 % 80 non
99 % des entreprises françaises qui ont
moins de 20 salariés cette entreprise là
probablement a quelques salariés quand
vous avez quelques salariés bah vous
avez pas de Responsable des Ressources
Humaines vous avez peut-être des fois
pas de comptable vous avez grosso modo
vous avez pas les ressources pour faire
les choses et a priori on est dans une
activité donc il y a pas la culture il y
a pas la connaissance il y a pas temps
ressources la relation avec
l'administration est très compliquée moi
ce que ce qui pourrait être intéressant
dans ce type mais dans ce type de
situation dans ce type de situation
qu'est-ce qui pour être intéressant
c'est qu'à ce moment-là bah l'inspecteur
face à cette situation bah disent
écoutez vous vous n'avez pas pu le faire
pour x ou y raison je les entends et
cetera euh bah je je vais monter le
dossier comme ça se fait dans plein de
pays oui je vais vous aider à faire en
sorte que vous puissiez former cet
apprenti je d'Ant mais je suis non il y
a une dérogation s'il y a une dérogation
qui est
possible pas est l'â de il pas 18 ans
etence vous dites vrai cet entrepreneur
est sans aucun doute sincère dans ce
qu'il dit il manque sans doute de moyens
pour pouvoir s'organiserpér mais on peut
pas on peut pas juger l'opportunité
d'appliquer le droit du travail en
fonction de la situation de chacune des
entreprises ça c'est pas possible si on
a une on a mis en place une autorisation
pour l'embauche des des apprentis
mineurs une autorisation spéciale c'est
bien parce que il y a ça a été un sujet
dans ce pays le travail des mineurs donc
exactement il il y a d'autres tout est
pas réductible au droit du travail le
droit du travail il doit quand même un
moment s'appliquer on peut pas tout
négocier et on peut pas composer
systématiquement l'application fonction
de la la loi c'est la loi c'est comme ça
dans toutes les sphères de la vie
économique et sociale aujourd'hui on
peut contester absolument n'importe quoi
devant les tribunaux là moi je
j'enseigne je tous les tous les
étudiants aujourd'hui peuvent contester
les notes qu'ils ont eu un examen on
peut contester l'utilisation de
n'importe quel matériel d'électroménager
on peut tout contester et le droit du
travail serait celui avec lequel on
devrait systématiquement composé qu'on
devrait négocier pour s'adapter à la
réalité de la vie économique je crois
que c'est pas possible il y a des règles
en matière d'hygiène de sécurité de
protection des travails de mineurs des
règles essentielles d'ordre public de
protection des salariés il faut trouver
d'autres moyens de les rendre possibles
pour les petites entreprise sans
remettre en cause des gar don certains
disent qu'elle est quelque fois trop
contraignante Florence barbout euh vous
dites quoi vous êtes dans ce genre de
situation face à un entrepreneur qui
vous dit mais je fais comment je je peux
pas travailler dans ces conditions-là
vous dites quoi je aider jeis vous aider
je garde mon calme parce que c'est
souvent effectivement bah c'est souvent
des situations qu'on rencontre
régulièrement qui est de du chantage à
l'emploi c'est-à-dire si vous nous
imposez les règles de sécurité ben on
sera obligé euh soit de retirer
l'apprenti soit de et donc c'est par de
chantage à l'emploi vous moi je parle
oui oui souvent c'est du chantage à
l'emploi bien sûr enfin c'est souvent
des ça arrive souvent oui benah
puisqu'on peut pas faire ça ben on va
arrêter puis on va licencier la personne
voilà donc là c'est ça ça porte sur
l'apprenti bon l'apprenti je pense qu'il
y a dû avoir une solution de trouver
c'est-à-dire déjà de toute façon il ne
pourra pas utiliser la machine qui n'est
pas conforme puisqu'il y a une plieuse
qui est pas conforme là il y aura pas de
dérogation possible pour lui mais si les
autres machines dans l'atelier ce qu'on
ne voit pas sont sont en conformité
probablement que l'inspecteur du travail
s'il y a pas d'autres infractions graves
qu'on voit pas dans le reportage
accordera la dérogation sauf pour les
machines qui son pas estce que ça vous
est arrivé de prendre des décisions qui
avaient effectivement pour conséquence
de mettre des gens au chauvage de fait
bah écoutez moi j'avoue que j'ai
toujours résisté au chatage à l'emploi
et j'ai jamais vu de licenciement
derrière hein je pense que c'est souvent
un argument qu'on nous donne et en fin
de compte derrière souvent il est pas
appliqué parce que souvent on a besoin
quand même des salariés pour faire
tourner l'entreprise vra donc donc bon
c'est un chantage du compte on vous dit
que c'est pas possible et puis si vous
restez ferme on fait les aménagements
qu'il faut et on se met en conformité VO
c'est ce que j'ai dit là je ne sais pas
du tout quelles suites ont été données
par la contrleuse mais ils vont la
contrôleuse son travail ça va être de
conduire et d'imposer d' conduire
l'entreprise à appliquer la
règlementation du travaille av employer
différents moyens soit c'est un moyen
coercitif parce qu'elle estime que la
situation est absolument épouvantable et
donc là elle va être très très ferme
tout de suite soit elle dit bon ben on
vous laisse du temps pour vous mettre en
conformité elle va et et vous-même
pouvez prendre des sanctions immédiates
ah oui bien sûr là la personne passé par
un juge ou ah bah attention on ne
prononce pas de sanction hein on relève
des infractions hein par procè
ure
rés
ouédure nous donne jamais de sanction en
direct moi je suis complètement
convaincu que on ne peut pas au nom d'un
chantage à l'emploi demander à ce que la
loi ne s'applique pas dans les
entreprises je crois que c'est une
problématique qui est inentendable
inacceptable du point de vue de la
République mais maintenant quand
j'entends monsieur qui est un
entrepreneur qui va de de la mise au
travail dans des cadres particulier
d'ingénieur jusqu'à l'aide à domicile
pourquoi est-ce que ces PME ne se
regroupent pas pour avoir un minimum
d'assistance juridique comptable et bien
entendu ça non ça fait 30 ans que ça se
faisait dans les districts italiens je
peux vous dire la mise en
commun c'est pas une façon pour vous
d'échapper ce qu'on appelle les effets
de se c'est pas avoir les comités
entreprise et faire maintenir des
petites boîtes
indépendante vous mettez le doigt là où
ça fait on vous prend flagr c'est ça
c'est ça l'idée il y a cette
problématique là bon donc vous dites en
tout cas bien sûr moi je crois qu'on ne
peut pas demander au nom de l'emploi de
dire il ne faut pas appliquer le droit
dans la mesure où on sait que ça ça peut
aller jusqu'à 700 ou selon les années
700 à 600 morts par accident du travail
en France donc c'est pas quelque chose
qui laissez-moi travailler ne vous
occupez pas de mes affaires vous avez
tout à l'heure parler utiliser le terme
d'inquisition
oui non mais je crois que il faut
accepter l'idée que ce sont des
individus qui sont au travail c'est les
citoyens qui sont au travail c'est
normal qu'il a un droit de regard de la
société pour voir les conditions dans
lesquelles il trava c'est de l'enquête
on met des enquêtes et on n pas de droit
de
perquisition on a souvent on a souvent
un patron qui nous dit mais s'agissant
de la de la santé de la sécurité bien
évidemment il faut pas toucher à ce qui
existe c'est normal il peut pas y avoir
des morts sur les échafaudages mais tout
est lié en droit du travail la
réglementation sur le temps de travail
elle a une conséquence directe sur
l'état de santé la fatigue des salar qui
sont sur échage bon si on peut négocier
le temps de travail de façon indéfinie
en dérégulant complètement en organisant
les 38 les cadence ça a une conséquence
directe sur la santé la sécurité au
travail tout se tient donc on peut pas
dissoer tous les suj et si cette
réglementation est trop contraignante
éventuellement par rapport à ce qui se
passe ailleurs et est-ce que dans ce
caslà et si le patron lui est un peu
démuni pour faire bosser en France déjà
à des conditions que ne connaissent pas
ceux qui travaillent à l'extérieur ou
ceux qui viennent de l'extérieur exemple
avec encore une fois le documentaire
récemment j'ai verbalisé une entreprise
allemande qui venait retirer de la
miante en France et l'argument de
l'employeur allemand c'était
effectivement de dire que c'était le
droit allemand qui s'appliquait en
France
sur qui s'appliquait pour les salar
allemands en tout cas moi j'ai des
Polonais marieclaude a des Polonais Mar
a des Polonais et il y a des allem ou ou
ouis ouis alors qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qu'il voulait faire tes
allemands il venaent faire un chantier
de désamiantage ils avaient demandé à un
artisan français de le faire et quand
ils se sont aperçus que le droit
français était très enfin plus
protecteur ils se sont tournés vers
l'entreprise allemande c'est une
nouvelle façon de de contourner
l'application de la loi h
ou c'est de toute façon une façon de
faire des économies mais éluder la
réglementation la plus contraignante
c'est c'est facile toi sur ton chantier
de désamiantage euh il a été clair le
gars hein c'est c'est moins compliqué
d'appliquer la réglementation allemande
que la réglementation française je vais
chercher des Allemands alors Florence
barbouté par exemple ça autre argument
où on vous dit on n'est pas sur une île
il y a quand même d'autres pays il y a
de la concurrence il y a des règles
sociales qui sont moins contraignantes
éventuellement ailleurs il y a du
dumping social et pas seulement qui
vient de la Chine ça peut venir de la
Roumanie voire même de pays plus proche
bon qu'est-ce qu'on fait je suis chef
d'entreprise comment je fais bien déjà
quand vous êtes chef d'entreprise que
vous embauchez une entreprise allemande
lu faites appliquer la réglementation
française parce que c'est le principe
donc en matière d'hygiène sécurité de de
droit du travail c'est la réglementation
française qui s'applique mais notamment
par exemple au niveau du du salaire le
salaire c'est le salaire conventionnel
qui s'applique pour les entreprises qui
qui emploi des des personnes étrangères
bon mais les charges sont pas les mêmes
en français qu'il y a aussi des périodes
pendant lesquelles on peut faire venir
bosser en France des Polonais et cetera
qui vont dans un premier temps sur une
duré limitée fonctionner avec les
charges de leur pays d'origine je cro
que c'est comme ça que ça se passe
au dit est-ce qu'on a pas à travers nos
codes et nos réglementations bah est-ce
qu'on a pas des boulets à à tirer qui
nous empêche d'être compétitif c'est ce
que disent j'imagine beaucoup les
entrepreneurs lorsqu'il s'agit là on a
un chantier sur laamante lorsqu'il
s'agit de la santé des salariés faut
faut être intransigeent effectivement
faut faut faut condamner ce type de
pratique non non mais faut condamner ce
type de pratique après on n'est pas sur
une île ça c'est sûr on est dans une
compétition mondiale et on n'est pas en
France hein contre contraement à ce qui
dit dans le reportage on est en Europe
on est en Europe on a des voisins
euh tout proche qui effectivement ont
des coûts du travail notamment beaucoup
plus compétitifs et qu'est-ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui moi je connais un
certain nombre d'entrepreneurs bah qui
non seulement qui qui ne délocalisent
pas mais qui se développe à
l'international notamment en Europe
parce que c'est beaucoup moins
contraignant pour eux et c'est pas
qu'une histoire de coût du travail là
c'est surtout une histoire de
complexification de la réglementation
française on un COD des impôts qui pèse
1 kg et demi un code du travail de 3000
bientôt 3500 pages avec trois pages
nouvelles par par
semaine à un moment donné il faut qu'on
puisse simplifier la vie de tout le
monde et je pense que ça simplifiera
aussi la vie des salariés on le de
travail vous l'avez avec vous non ah non
il est trop lourd je l'ai pas emmené
dans ma valise il est trop lourd bien et
vous trouvez vous-même qu'il pratiquez
tous les jours qu'il est il est devenu
obsolet trop compliqué trop Toufu c'est
plus possible je je crois qu'il y avait
600 articles en 73 et qu' en a à peu
près 10000 aujourd'hui si j'ai bien
compris donc c'est une inflation comme
ça l'inflation raisonnable mais alors
moi je je porterai pas enfin on est en
tant qu'inspecteur du travail on est on
applique la réglementation qui nous
arrive donc c'est pas nous he qui
faisons la réglementation c'est le
législat je dis pas ça mais vous qui
pratiquez tous les jours ce code est
vous mais parce qu'on dit souvent vous
le trouvez pas trop
compliqué écoutez on le trouve il est il
est devenu complexe parce que notre
société devient complexe aussi et puis
aussi que on ne souhaite pas dans notre
société appliquer des règles simples on
veut des règles simples avec beaucoup de
dérogations pour faire pour accéder à la
demande de beaucoup de de secteurs
professionnels et cetera ce qui fait
qu'on arrive à un code du travail
effectivement qui peut apparaître
complexe alors moi je dirais qu'en
matière d'hygiène sécurité je je trouve
qu'il s'est beaucoup amélioré parce que
les règles sont devenus plus des
principes et des objectifs à atteindre
que des des règles absolument
contraignant je a quand même un poid
vous vousmême il dans le code du travail
attention il n'y a pas que de
l'inspection du travail vous avez aussi
tout ce qui est régi la la formation
professionnelle et cetera he donc je
veux dire vous avez plusieurs parties
dans le COD par V qu'on parle un
peu quand même des des mots aujourd'hui
qui frappent le salarié attention avec
ce débat moi je suis complètement
d'accord le poids du Code du travail ces
dernières années c'est d'ailleurs
d'abord le poids de la déréglementation
quand vous écrivez que le temps de
travail se calcule sur la semaine et
qu'il est 39h hier 35h aujourd'hui ça
prend de lignes dans le code du travail
quand vous expliquez sur des pages et
des dizaines de page qu'on peut
travailler par cycle moduler le temps de
travail annualiser le temps de travail
c'est sur une demande patronale et sur
une pression patronale qu'on a permis la
déréglementation du travail toute la loi
de sécurisation de l'emploi là dont on
vient de parler laani sur l'emploi
récent se traduit par des de nombreuses
nouvelles pages sur la procédure de plan
social d'un code du travail souvent le
rè Lee du travail je crois depuis les
lois au routes 82 il a d tripl et c'est
d'abord et beaucoup le poid d'une
déréglementation du travail du temps de
travail quand même c'est un raccourci un
peu rapide parce qu'on on applique quand
même le principe de dialogue social il y
a a j'ai bien compris par rapport
auxtez Daniel est là jeais quand même
qu'on dise un mot peut-être sur bah ces
troubles musculolitiqu ces risques
psychosociaux à quoi il ressemble
aujourd'hui le marché du travail quels
sont bah les nouveaux mots qui arrivent
du fait de la crise notamment du fait de
rapports sociaux qui sont peut-être plus
tendus qu'avant du fait deune
compétitivité plus grande exiger des
salariés du fait surtout du nouveau
modèle managérial qui est en train de se
mettre en place bien c'està-dire depuis
les années 80 le le le le management
français c'est-à-dire l'ancien patronat
comme on disait avant a développé des
modalités d'organisation du travail de
gestion des salariés qui qui pose
beaucoup de problèmes et je crois que
une des raisons pour lesquelles le
travail devient douloureux souvent pour
les pour les salariés c'est parce que à
la base il y a un rapport de défiance
fondamentale des employeurs à à l'égard
de leurs salariés c'estàd que ils
pensent a priori que les salariés
voudront n'en faire qu'à leur tête
voudront en faire le moins possible ne
se pas beaucoup de tête de patron ça ah
je crois que c'est complètement présent
je ép alors ça a commencé en 80
excusez-moi dans les années
1980 ça continue je vais vous donner un
exemple dans les années vers 95 96 je me
souviendrai toujours j'avais euh j'étais
dans un séminaire de de responsable de
d'une grande entreprise dont je tirai le
nom et un de ces responsables me disait
vous savez notre travail maintenant
c'est de provoquer de l'amnésie il faut
que les salariés oublient ce qu'ils
étaient auparavant pour qu'ils
comprennent que le monde a changé et que
ce que nous voulons deux a beaucoup
changé aussi il faut qu'ils renonce
alors là je commande à leurs valeurs
professionnelles aux règles de leur
métier à la manière dont ils envisagent
le service public maintenant tout a
changé et il faut qu'ils comprennent que
ils doivent travailler selon les
critères que nous avons choisi en
fonction de la globalisation de la de
penser que le salari ne pense qu'à en
faire le moins possible il y a une marge
mais malheureusement il y a cette idée
que si on ne les contrôle pas si on
n'exerce pas une emprise à travers
l'organisation du travail sur les
salariés ils ne vont pas être à la
hauteur de ce qu'on
attend alors parce que ça du coup ça se
traduit par une politique de
déstabilisation systématique des
salariés ce à quoi on assiste c'est une
politique de changement frénétiique qui
prend l'allure de structuration de
service de département de recomposition
de métier de
trans écoutez pas du tout pas du tout du
tout pas du toutit 20 ans que je trava
en entreprise
sincèrement000 entreises me disent tous
que c'est vrai ils me disent oui nous
sommes dans une période de
transformation permanent ils le disent
tous tous les
responsablesation excuse-mi alors on est
d'accord donc il y a restructuration
permanente je finis parce que c'est très
important mobilité systématique
déménagement externalisation changement
de logiciel pourquoi alors donc
insécurité du salarié c'est ça que vous
dites une un inconfort permanent
c'est-à-dire que les salariés ne
maîtrisent plus ne maîtrisent plus le
contenu de leur travail ne peuvent pare
les entreprises pareil les entrepreneurs
je veux dire aujourd'hui moi je suis
incapable je suis incapable de faire une
stratégie pour mon entreprise à 12 mois
parce pourquoi parce que le monde change
on est encore une fois pas sur une île
on doit s'adapter à la réalité
économique moi je sais pas quelle loi ou
quelles dispositions vont être mis en
place dans dans un mois dans 3 mois et
cetera qui va impacter directement sur
mon ACC quand le monde quand le monde
est de plus en plus incertain quand
l'environnement est de plus en plus
fluctuant il ne faut pas s'embarquer
dans un changement permanent où on ne
maîtrise plus rien au contraire il faut
conserver des repères professionnels qui
permettront au salariés de s'adapter à
ce changement à ce me
FL patr qui V vont vous dire c'est le
monde qui commande ça tout le monde peut
pas être fonctionnaire il y a des boîtes
qui
sontmis est
encore exactement les mêm modèles qu'
prou on parlait là ça c'est
peutêtre peut-être vrai pour des très
grandes entreprises malheureusement
en France on as très grandes entreprises
je le rappelais tout à l'heure on a 99 %
des entreprises qui ont moins de 20
salariés Ré en terme de salari du marché
de travail al en fait qu' a des
mutations a des mutations profondes
c'est sûr mais moi le le message que
j'ai envie de donner c'est un message
plutôt positif c'estàd que l'entreprise
c'est une formidable aventure humaine
une formidable aventure collective et
c'est le dernier c'est le dernier
ascenseur social qui existe j'ai pas
fait vous é que vous vous
étiez pessimiste on va dire survolu je
pense si vous voulez que on est dans on
est dans une mise
en mise en difficulté dans alors on dit
99 % des des entreprises ne sont pas
grandes mais si on compte en terme de
salariés il y a une un immense majorité
de salariés qui est quand même dans les
grandes entreprises et leurs
sous-traitants et leurs fournisseurs et
dans le service public et ces salariés
là vont mal en France il faut
s'interroger sur les raisons de de cette
souffrance dont on parle tout le il
l'mission par Fr au travail malêtre au
travail parce qu'on arrive au terme de
l'émission si fallait changer quelque
chose qu'est-ce qu'il faut changer pour
que ça aille un peu mieux je pas qu'il a
une idée làdessus donner j'ai du pouvoir
aux organisations syndicales et au
contrepouvoir dans l'entreprise
développer le dialogue social mais sans
faire du dialogue social le moyen
d'éviter l'application de la loi
c'est-à-dire que là et je pense très
précisément à l'évolution récente avec
la loi de sécurisation de l'emploi le
fameux ani sur l'emploi dont tout le
monde parle dans les dans dans les
milieux syndicaux et pas onau le
l'accord le la loi de sécurisation de
l'emploi l'accord national
interprofessionnel dont on a beaucoup
parlé sur la qui remodifie totalement le
droit du licenciement économique
notamment les dialogue social dans les
entreprises il faut faire attention à ce
que le dialogue social ne soit pas sous
le contrôle d'administration du
travail le moyen de déréglementer le
travail et de remettre en cause les
garanties sociales des salariés le
social doit garder sa fonction
d'amélioration de la condition
fondamentaux calmonsnous je dire un et
la réponse à ça c'est le c'est quand
même un dialogue social rénové c'est
aussi faire confiance aux compétences
professionnelles des salariés français
qui sont particulièrement développés
comparativement à d'autres pays on
compare tout le temps attendez voilà
parce qu'on compare tout le temps en
terme de cou de code du travail mais on
ne dit pas à quel point les Français ont
une qualité d'engagement dans le travail
comparativement à d'autres
paysut juste arrêter de considérer les
employeurs les patrons comme l'ennemi du
salarié je crois que on on va tous dans
le même sens on va tous dans le même
sens on va dans le sens de la création
de richesse d'emploi et dans le sens
aussi de de de la progression de notre
pays et je crois qu'on a on est tous
d'accord autour de la table sur cette
question là plus il y a de la richesse
plus tout le monde sera riche voilà
absolument et et moi les inspecteurs du
travail auront le travail mais je
voudrais dire aussi que ce que décrit ce
que décrit madame Linard il faut dire
aussi que de plus en plus les petites
entreprises appartiennent à des groupes
et que les centres de décision
s'évaporent de fait et donc il y a plus
de dialogue localement puisque les les
directeurs qui sont sur place dans les
entreprises dépendent vos interlocuteurs
en fait n'ont pas la mamise sur ce qui
se passe dans l'entreprise ils
appliquent des normes qui viennent
d'ailleurs ben pas des normes mais des
directions contraintes des contraintes
et donc du coup localement on a de moins
en moins d'interlocuteurs qui ont des
pouvoirs pour agir et ça c'est très
compliqué à la fois pour les
organisations syndicales qui se
retrouvent face à des directions
d'entreprise qui n'ont pas de prise sur
le fonctionnement de leur entreprise et
par pour on n pas de gens qui décident
autour de la table merci beaucoup merci
à vous tous et je ne pensais pas avant
de faire ce débat que le monde du
travail était à ce point euh en si
mauvais état que vous le décrivez vous
merci beaucoup merci Aurélie dafas qui a
préparé ce ce débat je vous rappelle
notre adresse internet je vous dis que
la semaine prochaine vous retrouverez
CLIRE Barsac pour parler du réveil
ouvrier en Asie tiens justement et puis
et bien nous on se retrouve dans 15
jours on parlera de la PCT la politique
agricole commune je sais pas encore pour
dire quoi mais je sais que ça sera
là-dessus voilà bonne semaine sur Public
Sénat
Marine Lepen sera l'invité de preuve par
tro la présidente du Front national